WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
OF HAVING A QUORUM TO GET THIS
MEETING STARTED.
WELCOME TO THE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HEARING
OF APRIL TWENTY FIFTH PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE.
THEREFORE BILLS UP IN OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY NOTHING IS ON
CONSENT THE BILLS THAT ARE UP IN.
COMMITTEE WILL COME UP IN
COMMITTEE -- MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU CALL THE ROLL BERMAN HERE
BERMAN HERE GALLAGHER.
CALDERON LOW.
LOW HERE MAYES MULLIN.
PRESIDENT MULLIN HERE WEBER.
EVER HEAR WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK
YOU AND I SEE THAT MISTER
SANTIAGO IS HERE READY TO
PRESENT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER BERMAN.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND WILL.
HE TO THE HURCH RECOMMENDATION
TO BE BRIEF.
I THINK IT'S CHAIR ABC SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WOULD ESTABLISH OPEN
SOURCE -- PAPER BALANCE JUSTIN'S
A PROGRAM TO AUTHORIZE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO ADMINISTER
MATCHING FUNDS TO PARTICIPATING
COUNTY SO THEY COULD SPEED UP
THE DEVELOPMENT CERTIFICATION.
AND GOVERNANCE IN DISTRIBUTION
OF OPEN SOURCE VOTING THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
I AND I NOW HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES WILL ALSO ELABORATE ON
THIS POINT GREG MAJOR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR --
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE CURRENTLY
PRESENT CALIFORNIA MONEY
CAMPAIGN WERE A PROUD TO SPONSOR
AT THIS BILL AND AND VERY
THANKFUL TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AS
WELLS AS SOME MEMBERS CHIU AND
GONZALEZ -- THIS IS THE TIME
WHEN I THINK WE'VE ALL SEEN THAT
ARE ELECTIONS ARE UNDER ATTACK --
AND THIS IS A TIME WHEN WE HAVE
SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN
UNFORTUNATELY THAT OUR ELECTION
SYSTEMS ARE NOT SECURE.
THE DEF CON THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN DEF CON SECURITY
CONFERENCE THAT TESTS VOTING
SYSTEMS -- FOUND A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THAT EVERY PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY TESTED --
WAS BREACHED IN SOME MANNER AND
THEY DECLARE THAT IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK -- WE AND AND MANY
OTHERS -- MANY OTHER COMPUTER
EXPERTS BELIEVE THAT OPEN SOURCE
A A PUBLICLY OWNED PAPER BALLOT
VOTING SYSTEMS WOULD BE MORE
SECURE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
COUNTERINTUITIVE -- BECAUSE YOU
THINK THAT -- THAT WHEN -- CODE
IS PUBLISHED THAT THE BAD GUYS
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE IT BUT THE
BAD GUYS AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HACK THE CODE ANYWAYS -- AS WE
HAVE WE SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
WHAT HAVING THE CODE IN PUBLIC
MEANS THAT THE GOOD GUYS CAN
LOOK AT THE DETAILS FIGURE OUT
THE PROBLEMS POINT OUT YOU GOT A
PROBLEM THERE GOT A SECURITY
ISSUE -- PLEASE FIX IT SO --
THAT'S WHY OPEN SOURCE IS MORE
SECURE FROM A BUDGETARY
STANDPOINT WILL ALSO SAVE --
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY
THAT ARE CURRENTLY PAID TO
PROPRIETARY VOTING MACHINES
THAT'S WHY THERE'S A LONG LIST
OF OF PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THIS
AND AND IT'S THE CHANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTIES ARE IN.
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
SYSTEMS -- THE MATCHING FUNDS
PROPOSED IN THIS IN THIS BILL
WILL HELP THEM DEVELOP IT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE GET IT
CERTIFIED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND THEN JUST AS IMPORTANTLY.
SHARE IT WITH OTHER -- COUNTIES
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE ONCE
IT'S DEVELOPED BY THE COUNTY
THAT BENEFIT FROM THIS EVERY
COUNTY IN THE STATE WILL BE ABLE
TO USE IT FOR FREE AND FACT
EVERY COUNT THE IN THE NATION
GREAT WILL BE ABLE TO USE A FREE
SO THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT THE
SYNERGY -- SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICKEL SADDAM
WAS CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION FOR FOR SIMILAR
REASONS REALLY WHEN WE LOOK AT
OPEN SOURCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AN INVESTMENT IN MUCH STRONGER
SECURITY.
BUT HAVING MORE EYES ON THE CODE
YOU'VE GOT MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SPOT OF MALICIOUS SAID
INTRUSIONS AS WELL AS SIMPLY
BUGS.
I'LL JUST BRIEFLY READ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IS OPEN
SOURCE SOFTWARE FAQ FREQUENTLY
ASKED QUESTIONS.
THE DOD STATES MAKING SOURCE
CODE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
SIGNIFICANTLY AIDS -- DEFENDERS
CONTINUOUS AND BROAD CARE VIEW
ENABLE BY PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
SOURCE CODE IMPROVE SOFTWARE
RELIABILITY AND SECURITY THROUGH
THE IDENTIFICATION AND
ELIMINATION OF DEFECTS MIGHT
OTHERWISE GOING RECOGNIZED BY
THE POOR DEVELOPMENT TEAM.
CONVERSELY WHEN SOURCE CODE IS
HIDDEN FROM THE PUBLIC ATTACKERS
CAN ATTACKED SOFTWARE ANYWAYS.
IN ADDITION TO SECURITY WE'RE
JUST POINT OUT THAT YES THIS
REALLY IS A DOWN PAYMENT TO TO
FUTURE COST SAVINGS WHEN YOU
HAVE OPEN SOURCE SOFTWARE.
THE LOWER COUNTIES CAN USE THIS
IS A REAL ABILITY TO DRIVE DOWN
COSTS.
JUST A FEW THE LAST YEAR WE DID
A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION AS
INITIAL DOWN PAYMENT FOR NEW
VOTING EQUIPMENT US WEST
ESTIMATES ARE.
THE NEEDS ARE IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS FOR UPDATING OUR VOTING
EQUIPMENT WE THINK THIS
INVESTMENT WILL PAY DIVIDENDS
THE STATE'S FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT FEEL FREE -- TO EITHER
QUICKLY COME TO THE MICROPHONE
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION WE CAN ALSO DO A SHOW
OF HANDS FOR FOLKS TO THIS ONE
THE SHOW ENDS.
THANK YOU IN MEMBER NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL HELLO MY NAME IS BRENT
TURN AROUND WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VOTING OFFICIALS
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING.
NOT ONLY CAVO BUT WANTED TO JUST --
A LINE COBOL WITH A FORMER WHITE
CHIEF -- WHITE HOUSE ETHICS
ATTORNEY RICHARD PAINTER AND
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JIM WOOLSEY
ALL IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER TURNER.
I THINK YOU EVER SACRAMENTO --
BUT ALSO JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT
IT WOULD BE GOOD IF THE SEWER
PUBLICLY OWNED -- VOTING
EQUIPMENT BUT I SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I'M. FOR I'M HERE WITH CLEAN
MONEY FROM SUNNYVALE AND I
MANAGE A T. FOR SMALL AND MEDIUM
BUSINESSES AND I WANT TO
STRONGLY SUPPORTED BECAUSE WHAT
HAS BEEN SAID.
BY.
OTHER PEOPLE HERE AS WELL IS
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE US
SAFE THANK YOU HAVE MUCH GOOD
WORK IN THE LONG RUN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OKAY AND I'M SURELY SHOWING US
KI<c.cyan> FROM PLEASANT HILL AND</c>
THE EAST BAY COORDINATOR
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GARY OF HEALTH A MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
GREG PENNINGTON SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MANY CAMPAIGN
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
BARBER WINDHAM ATHERTON I'M ON
THE BOARD THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
DEBORAH LUNDGREN FROM MOUNTAIN
VIEW I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ASK
FOR YOUR YES VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ROOM COULD TELL PROFESSIONALS
OPERATE HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I SERVANTS AND WILL VISOR
COMMITTEE FOR SAN FRANCISCO'S
OFFICERS VOTING EFFORT -- AND I
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CAT CARRILLO ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN END OF THE
SOUTH.
SACRAMENTO SENIOR CITIZENS
ALLIANCE WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
PROVIDER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE SPELL THANK
YOU.
SURE ACOSTA FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
A RETIRED SOFTWARE ENGINEER I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THINK THINK THANK YOU.
SHANE MCLEOD SACRAMENTO --
REPRESENTING MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
WHEN HEIDI COOPER MENLO PARK?
AND I WANT TO US TO ASSURE A
DEMOCRACY.
I DON'T FEEL WE HAVE A DEMOCRACY
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU LINE.
GORDON MILLER WALNUT CREEK
CALIFORNIA CLAIM MONEY CAMPAIGN
AND CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS SUPPORT THIS
BILL FOR NATIONAL SECURITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RAY CHECK A TEENY FROM CONCORD
FOR CLEAN MONEY.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
DAVID NEWS WENGER SUNNYVALE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND I
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI PEPPER MAR FROM NEWARK I'M
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MANY CAMPAIGN
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS
SO MUCH THINKING.
HELLO AMANDA GRIZ YAK FROM HERE
CALIFORNIA NINE FOUR FIVE FOUR
TWO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY THANK YOU.
JUDY JACKSON FROM BERKELEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY THANK YOU.
POWER RANDALL FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
AMY HUEY FROM ONE CREEK WITH
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR MORE
SECURE ELECTIONS THANK YOU.
GRAND HE WEEK FOR WATER CREEK
ALSO LIKELY TO VOTE YES ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO NAY THE CAMPBELL MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M CAROL CONCERT FROM OAK
GROVE CALIFORNIA WITH CLEAN MANY
AND I GREW I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SUSAN SETTER HOME SAN FRANCISCO
CLEAN MANY CAMPAIGN PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THAT'S WHEN OAKLAND REPRESENTING
THE PEACE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE AMONG CLEAR
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH IN OAKLAND.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
FINGER THANK YOU.
PRESENCE BROUGH IT FROM SERVICES
GO EAST BAY.
REPRESENT MEAN REPRESENT US
OAKLAND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
JIM DAVIDSON FROM LASALLE TOASTS
WITH CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND
A SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JACQUELYN DOOR FROM SACRAMENTO
IN CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HURDLE TIPPING FROM SAN JOSE
POLICE SUPPORT THE BILL I DO
THANK YOU.
DAVID SMITH FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL VALLEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
NANCY NFL ALTHOUGH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NANCY OUT WELL COUNTY OF CINEMA
RETIREE -- CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
AND PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL LET
CALIFORNIA LEAD THE WAY WE
REALLY NEED IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
KEVIN LOVE CHAIR COVER ANYTHING
MANY ACTION FUND PLEASE SUPPORT
THANKS.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MANY CAMPAIGN
BOARD I ALSO SERVE ON THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
A CITIZENS ADVISORY COMMISSION
ON ELECTIONS PLEASE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO SEE
SOMEBODY CONSTITUENTS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE MS GONZALEZ WOULD
YOU LIKE TO THINK I THINK THE
BILL I THINK WE DECIDED I'LL GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE -- FOR US ARE TO
YOU THEN WE BROUGHT BACK SORRY
BUT THAT'LL BE EASIER.
ANY COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTION SECONDS.
JUST SIX RISK CHERYL.
MOTION THAT THE SECOND GOT A
SECOND AND JUST APPLAUDING BOTH
AUTHORS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUE AND PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS MULLIN
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SAYING NONE THIS IS
ALSO THE LIKE TO TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I'M YOU KNOW I'M I'M PROUD
TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR WITH.
MISTER SANTIAGO MISTER TO ON
THIS BILL AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE BECAUSE I THINK AT
FIRST IT'S CONFUSING FOR FOR LAY
FOLKS TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT THE OPEN SOURCE IDEA.
AND THE FACT THAT IF YOU HAVE
MORE EYES LOOKING AT DATA IT'S
ACTUALLY BETTER DEMOCRACY DIES
IN DARKNESS WE KNOW THIS AND
WHEN YOU HAVE A SINGLE
CORPORATION THAT'S COMPLETELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHETHER NOT
SOMETHING CAN BE HACKED.
IT'S FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE
HACKED THEN YOU IF YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE PROFESSIONALS IN WHITE
HATS LOOKING AT THAT DATA AND
HAVING OPEN SOURCE SO THE MORE I
LEARNED ABOUT IT I BECAME A TRUE
BELIEVER AND I THINK THE MORE.
WE EXPLAIN IT CALIFORNIANS THEY
WELL AS WELL AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS VERY TRANSPARENT GOOD
MEASURE THANK YOU SO AMERICANS
ALLOWS.
PURCHASING A VOTING SYSTEM THAT
IS VERIFIABLE ACCURATE SECURE
TRANSPARENT AND MEETS THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THE VOTERS IS A TOUGH
TASK TO ACCOMPLISH.
PARTICULARLY WHEN THERE ARE FEW
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS -- AS SUCH I
THINK THERE'S VALUE IN
EXPLORATIONS DEFINITELY
INCLUDING OPEN SOURCE SOFTWARE
OPEN SOURCE VOTING SYSTEMS AS IS
BEEN DESCRIBED AS SO MANY FOLKS --
SOME HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND RECOMMENDING AND I VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
pAPPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I'D GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON I LOW.
LOW I'M MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXUS IS SOMEONE NUMBER
[inaudible]
RAY IS [inaudible]
IBM [inaudible] THREE WITH A. B..
WELL THAT'S NOT A LUCKY NUMBER.
ITEM AB.
ONE SIX SIX SIX THE ONE THE ONE
IN THE DOES IT YEAH PERFECT.
THANK GOD ABOUT THE ONE DAY
THAT'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT.
CENSUS.
TWENTY TWENTY OFFICE TO PARTNER
WITH LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO MAKE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS AVAILABLE
AT SCHOOL SITES TO STUDENTS
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT SCHOOLS OFFER
THE ONE OF THOSE SAFE HAVENS
EVERYBODY TRUSTS THE SCHOOLS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE AN
ACCURATE COUNT -- AND I WANT TO
PERSONALLY APPLAUD THE CHAIRS
LEADERSHIP.
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE CENSUS LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. TO IN ALL OF
YOUR EFFORTS TO ENGAGE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS CHRISTOPHER SANTOS
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH CHIP Là
GREAT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE FOR SIGNS OF CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ARE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
IN PREVIOUS YEARS DURING THE
SENSITIVE -- ALWAYS SEEM
CHALLENGES AND COUNTING
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS
THAT ARE HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES.
ARE SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF TRUST IN THE GOVERNMENT LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
CENSUS LANGUAGE BARRIERS TO
COMPLETE THE CENSUS DISTRACTIONS
FROM ABOUT THE AS COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
AND OTHER REASONS THAT ARE
REALLY LONG TOO LONG TO LIST
THIS UPCOMING THOUSAND CENSUS WE
FACE ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES GIVEN
THE POLITICAL CLIMATE IN THE
POSSIBILITY OF A CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION.
THIS IS WHY CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
ENSURE THAT THE EFFORTS TO
INVEST IN THE SENSES ARE
SIGNIFICANT EFFICIENT TO REACH
THE HARD TO REACH COMMUNITIES.
THAT ALL TRUST AMBASSADORS TAKE
THEIR FAIR SHARE RESPONSIBILITY
AS CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
SURE THAT'S TAKEN ON AFFIRMATIVE
POSITION TO SAY YES TO THE
SENSES AND NOTIFY YOUR AS WE
HAVE LUNCH OR CAMPAIGN.
CONTAMINANTS CONTIGO WE ARE
COUNTING ON YOU.
HOWEVER WE CANNOT DO THIS ALONE
SCHOOLS TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS PLAY CRITICAL
ROLES TRUST THE MESSENGERS.
WE AT AS THEY HAVE EXPERTISE AND
HOW TO COMMUNICATE TO THESE
COMMUNITIES FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANYONE ELSE'S IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE BRING IT
BACK TO COLLEAGUES WITH A BI
PARTISAN MOTION AND SECOND.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER
GALLAGHER THIS VERY QUICKLY --
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
IT'S THIS IS ALL ALSO SOME IS
VERY CLOSE TO MY HEART AS WELL
AS YOU KNOW WITH THE WILDFIRE
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN BUTTE
COUNTY IN AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE PLUS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED.
YOU KNOW THE REALLY DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THAT COUNT THAT WE
GET.
TO HARD TO REACH POPULATIONS
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED -- AND YOU KNOW I
THINK BY USING.
YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR OUR OUR
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT CAN
REALLY HELP DO THAT RIGHT NOW.
IN IN IN MY DISTRICT IT'S THE
SCHOOLS THERE IN MANY WAYS
TRYING TO HELP KEEP PEOPLE
TOGETHER KEEP STUDENTS TOGETHER --
AND YOU KNOW -- OF HELPING KINDA
HELP KEEP THAT.
THAT CORE TOGETHER SO APPRECIATE
THIS BILL MINUTES SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR.
MS REYES WE LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE ALSO THAT
THIS HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A AS
A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE LATINO
CAUCUS.
US ON BEHALF OF THE CAUCUS IN
ON'T.
THE REST OF THE POPULATION
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AS
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS I'M
ACUTELY AWARE.
OF THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IN
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE COUNTED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
AND THIS BILL WILL ASSIST IN THE
STATEWIDE EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO
HARD TO COUNT POPULATIONS AND
ENSURE THEIR EDUCATED ACTIVATED
AND ENCOURAGED TO FILL OUT.
THE CENSUS QUESTIONNAIRE I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR -- AS WE'VE
SEEN FOR THE MOTION TO THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE THIS IS
A BIPARTISAN ISSUE THIS IS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA.
ON AND MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS ARE COUNTED -- SO I'M
PROUD AND AND HAPPY AND EXCITED
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN HI GALLAGHER GALLAGHER
AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WHETHER.
WEBER I THAT IS UNANIMOUSLY
SUPPORTED SEVEN OF HAUTE --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT UP WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'VE GOT AB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN MISTER MULLIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTED EVEN JONES
FOR HIS EXTENSIVE WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND TO INDICATE THAT I WANT TO
OF STEPS EXCEPT THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN SEEKS TO
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE
ACT. TO COVER ISSUE ADS THAT ARE
INTENDED INFLUENCE LEGISLATIVE
AND ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS AND
ALSO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE FOR
ELECTION HEARING COMMUNICATIONS
THAT ATTACKER SUPPORT CANDIDATES
DURING ELECTION SEASON.
WITHOUT EXPRESSLY ADVOCATING FOR
THEIR ELECTION OR DEFEAT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I AUTHORED
AB TWO FOUR NINE THE CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW.
THAT IS CLOSE ACT MADE STRIDES
IN ADDRESSING PREVIOUS LACKS
CAMPAIGN FINANCE DISCLOSURE
POLICIES THE MEASURE APPROVED
THE CLARITY OF THE FORMATTING OF
DISCLOSURES OF TOP FUNDERS.
A BALLOT MEASURE AN INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE ADS ON TV RADIO
PRINT AND COMMON FORMS OF
ELECTRONIC MEDIA.
IT ALSO ESTABLISH NEW EARMARKING
RULES TO IDENTIFY ORIGINAL
DONORS TO COMMITTEES AND BALLOT
MEASURES.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED THE FOLLOW
UP LEGISLATION AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT THE SOCIAL MEDIA
DISCLOSE ACT WHICH EXTENDS TO
FOUR NINES REQUIREMENTS TO COVER
ADDS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES PERSON TO
SPEND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
MORE IN ELECTION HEARING
COMMUNICATIONS WITHIN FORTY FIVE
DAYS OF AN ELECTION TO REPORT
THE PAYMENT.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
DISCLOSURE ON SUCH ADS NO SUCH
REQUIREMENT EXISTS FOR ISSUE
ADVERTISING ISSUE ADVERTISEMENTS
THAT ATTEMPT TO PRESSURE
LEGISLATORS TO INFLUENCE
LEGISLATIVE OUTCOMES.
ARE A GROWING ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR
GROUP CALLED CAL INNOVATES
PLACED OVER FOUR HUNDRED ADS ON
FACEBOOK TRYING TO KILL A NET
NEUTRALITY BILL.
THIS YEAR THERE ARE SEVERAL ADS
RUNNING ON VARIOUS FORMS OF
MEDIA CLEARLY DESIGNED TO
MOTIVATE PUBLIC INTERACTION WITH
LEGISLATORS ON ISSUES SUCH AS
POLICE USE OF FORCE.
AS WELL AS LOCAL HOUSE.
PARTY LOCAL HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
MOVIE CLEAR THERE IS NOTHING
WRONG IN FACT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
PUBLIC INTERACTION IN THE
PROCESS OF LAWMAKING.
MY ONLY GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PUBLIC IS INFORMED AS
TO WHO IS ACTUALLY PAYING FOR
THESE ADS WHO'S BEHIND THESE ADS.
WHICH ARE REQUESTING THAT
PARTICIPATION IF THE AT IS BEING
PAID FOR BY CERTAIN INDUSTRY OR
NONPROFIT GROUP THE PUBLIC MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER THE
GROUP'S INTEREST OF LINE WITH
THEIR INDIVIDUAL INTERESTS.
THAT'S IT THAT'S THE PRINCIPLE
THE BILL LAST YEAR.
THE BRIGHT COALITION BLANKETED
THE AIRWAVES WITH MESSAGES
DEFUSING BLAME FOR WILDFIRES
WITHOUT SAYING WHO PAID FOR THE
ADS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN PGA ANY SPENT
OVER SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON CALL
GRASSROOTS ANOTHER ADVOCACY
RELATED TO STATE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS.
CLEARLY DESIGNED TO SHAPE PUBLIC
OPINION.
AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN DOESN'T IN
ANY WAY LIMIT THAT ACT ACTIVITY
YOUR THAT ABILITY.
IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT GROUPS
OR INDIVIDUALS BE CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED IN THE AD AS THE TOP
FUNDERS.
ELECTIONEERING COMMUNICATIONS
THAT TARGET CANDIDATES WITHOUT
EXPRESSLY ADVOCATING FOR THEIR
ELECTION OR DEFEAT ARE ALSO A
GROWING PROBLEM WITH OVER TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND REPORTED
EXPENDITURES SINCE.
TWENTY TEN THEY ARE THERE IS A
LOOPHOLE IN AB TWO FOUR NIGHTS
REQUIREMENT THAT INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE ADS FOR OR AGAINST
CANDIDATES MUST CLEARLY SHOW
THEIR TOP THREE FINDERS AND WE
ARE TRYING TO CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE.
WITH THE SECOND PROVISION TWELVE
SEVENTEEN AS A STRAIGHT FOR
PROPOSAL IS SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
SAME PRINCIPLES THIS LEGISLATURE
APPROVED BY TWO THIRDS MAJORITY
IN OUR LAST SESSION TO
ADVERTISEMENT SEEKING TO AFFECT
PUBLIC POLICY.
THE SAME AS THOSE SEEKING TO
IMPACT ELECTIONS I'VE BEEN
WORKING EXTENSIVELY WITH
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS I
INDICATED. TO GET THE BILL INTO
ITS CURRENT STATE WHERE ENGAGE
WITH THE F. PPC A LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THEM AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS TO ADDRESS.
ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
THAT'LL TURN IT OVER -- TO MY
CHIEF SUPPORTERS AT THE TABLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND PLEASE
GIVE IT TWO MINUTES EACH THE
THANK YOU A TREND LINE PRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN AGAIN A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND AND AND MEMBERS -- WE
THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
ON THE DISCLOSE ACT THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS -- THIS BILL IS IS
CLOSING IN IMPORTANT LOOPHOLE IN
IN THE DISCLOSE ACT -- THE THESE.
AND IT IS NARROWLY TAILORED TO
TO DO SO AS HE DESCRIBED RIGHT
NOW THERE IS A SPECIALLY
LOOPHOLE WITH ELECTIONEERING
COMMUNICATIONS WHERE THEY CAN
ATTACK CANDIDATES WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF THE GENERAL ELECTION
THIRTY DAYS OF THE PRIMARY
WITHOUT -- EXPRESSLY ADVOCATING
FOR THEIR SUPPORTER TO FEET --
THE SUPREME COURT IN CITIZENS
UNITED EIGHT OUT OF THE NINE
JUSTICES -- SAID THAT THOSE WERE
CONCERT IT WAS CONSTITUTIONAL --
TO REQUIRED DISCLOSURE ON THOSE
TYPES OF ADS SO WE BELIEVE IT'S
A STRONGLY -- THE CASE HERE AND
THEN ISSUE ADVOCACY
ADVERTISEMENTS VERY NARROWLY
TERREL TAYLOR DOES NOT GOING.
TO STOP SIERRA CLUB FROM SAYING
YOU KNOW -- WE NEED TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE -- OR THE NRA
FROM SAYING YOU KNOW -- WE WE WE
DON'T NEED CONTROL CONTROL IT'S
ONLY WHEN A ADD TARGETS A
SPECIFIC PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
A SPORT SPECIFIC ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTION AND ASKED.
THE PEOPLE TO TAKE ACTION BY
COULD CONTACTING THEIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEGISLATOR THAT'S WE
BELIEVES ARE CLEARLY POLITICAL
ADS WHEN THEY DO THAT AND THOSE
NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES THAT'S
WHAT'S BEEN CRAFTED THIS WAY --
IT WHAT WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE
TO EXTENDED THE DISCLOSE THAT
REQUIREMENTS TO IT AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I MANAGER MISS FISHER
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
A CALIFORNIA OF THE LEAGUE IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN TO EXTEND THE
CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT TO COVER
BOTH ELECTIONEERING
COMMUNICATIONS.
I AN ISSUE ADS INTENDED TO
INFLUENCE LEGISLATIVE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS.
THE LEAGUE HAS A HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING POLITICAL ADVERTISED
ADVERTISEMENT DISCLOSURES WHICH
IS WHY WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT.
TO MAKE DISCLOSURES ON BALLOT
MEASURES IN INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES EXPENDITURE
ADVERTISEMENTS CLEARLY LEGIBLE A
AND TO DISCLOSE THE TRUTH
UNDERSUPPLY.
EGGMAN SCISSORS THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS FOR DISCLOSURE AND
TRANSPARENCY AS DIRECT --
CAMPAIGNER ADVERTISING. FOR ALL
INTENTS AND PURPOSES ISSUE
ADVERT ADVOCACY ADVERTISEMENTS
ASSETS ARE DEFINED AND AB.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN OUR POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS.
IF IT ADDED TAXES SUPPORTS US
SPECIFIC BILL AND ASK VOTERS TO
CONTACT THEIR LEGISLATORS AS WE
ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE.
THIS IS A POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENT AND SHOULD CLEARLY
DISCLOSE WHO PAYS FOR IT AS MUCH
AS ANY OTHER POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENT.
WITH IT THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. NINE A YEP AND NAME OF
ORGANIZATION OR CITY OR FROM AND
POSITION ON THE BILL.
THE GOOD SIDE ON WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAROL BADGER FROM SANFRANCISCO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
ALLEN BROKER ON HERE BOTH AS A
MEMBER OF CLEAN MONEY.
I AM AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN I
WOULD BE HER IN EITHER BASIS MY
MANAGE IT AND I'M VERY WELL
WORLD AWARE OF WHAT'S COMING
DOWN THE TUBES.
RIGHT NOW THE BIGGEST YOU SEE I
SEE COMING UP FOR A USUAL
INTELLIGENCE IS INTEGRATING
POSITION ON THE CHANGING.
ATTITUDES [inaudible]
PROBABLY STE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY APOLOGIES MISTER CHAIR NO
PROBLEM THANK YOU.
DOUG TROUBLE INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO.
EXCUSE ME AND INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG AND AND
NOT STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
CITY WHEREVER LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PEACE FREEDOM
PARTY CALIFORNIA IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JUDY JACKSON BERKELEY IN SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SUSAN SAID HER HOME SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA THE MONEY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BARBARA WINDHAM METHOD IN
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS AN INCREASE OUR
TRUST IN THE GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
DAVID NEWS WENGER SUNNYVALE
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREG PENNINGTON SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE PROTECT TRANSPARENCY IN
OUR DEMOCRACY PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR RUBBER CALLED FOR SECOND A
CALIFORNIA PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PATCH WHEN OAKLAND REPRESENTING
THE PEACE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE OF MONCLER
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH AND
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY THANK YOU
THINK THEY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GARY APPEL MILL VALLEY CLEAN
MONEY PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GORDON MILLER WALNUT CREEK CLEAN
MONEY CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
CHART AMERICANS PLEASE SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEN HEIDI COOPER MENLO PARK
CLEAN MONEY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINETEEN F. PALO ALTO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ELLEN CHAPMAN SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND
INDIVISIBLE SEGMENT OF STATE
STRONG IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REGIONAL BANKS SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH LANGER IN
MOUNTAIN VIEW CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORTED NOW FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CAN'T CARRILLO FROM SACRAMENTO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
AND SOUTH SACRAMENTO SENIOR
CITIZENS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
PRESENCE BROUGH IT FROM THE EAST
BAY OAKLAND AREA.
REPRESENTING REPRESENT US
OAKLAND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
PAUL RANDALL SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AMANDA GRIZZARD FROM HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA NINE FOUR FIVE FOUR
TWO I SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR
TRANSPARENT ELECTIONEERING THANK
YOU.
HOWEVER MORE FROM NEWARK
CALIFORNIA NINE FOUR FIVE SIX
ZERO AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JIM DAVIDSON FROM WAS AALTO'S
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JACQUELYN DOOR FROM SACRAMENTO
IN CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY PLEASE
VOTE I FOR TRANSPARENCY THANK
YOU.
SURELY SHOWING US GAY FROM
PLEASANT HILL CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CAROL CANCER FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND A CLEAN MONEY --
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS
THANK YOU.
GREAT CHECK A TEENY FROM CONCORD
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHTY CAMPBELL PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GRANT HE WEEK WANTED CREEK
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
AMY HERE WE FROM ON IT CREATE A
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND
INDIVISIBLE RESISTORS OF WALNUT
CREEK PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
DAVID SMITH FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
SURE ACROSS FROM SACRAMENTO -- I
A SUPPORTS BILL ASK YOU TOO
THANKS THANK YOU.
HELL TIPPING SAN JOSE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL I HOPE YOU DO
TOO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ROCKETS OUT FROM SAN FRANCISCO
MEMBER CAO FRANKLY MONEY
INSTRUCTS SPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA AND PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANKS.
SHANE MCLEOD OF SACRAMENTO
FORMER CAMPAIGN MANAGER VOTERS
RIGHT TO KNOW AND REPRESENTING
I'M HERE REPRESENTING NO.
MONEY OUT VOTERS IN PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL SUN SUNLIGHT
IS THE BEST DISINFECTANT THANK
YOU.
KEVIN OFF CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MANY ACTION FUND PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- CHAPTER TO
KIA.
PUBLIC AB TICKET -- HOW MEMBER
CARE A MEMBER OF A NUMBER OF
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS PLEASE
SUPPORT GETTING MONEY OUT OF
POLITICS THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
THE NC OUT WELL COUNTY OF CINEMA.
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN.
I SUPPORT THE BILL --
TRANSPARENCY FROM CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO LEAD THE WAY THANK YOU.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MANY CAMPAIGN BOARD OF DIRECTORS
SAN JOSE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND HE DIDN'T ANY ADDITIONAL IN
THIS ISN'T SUPPORT SING NINE ANY
ADDITIONAL OR ANY WITNESSES AT
ALL AND OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COLLEGE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER MISS.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY -- THIS
ALSO APPLIES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
YES IT DOES YES IT THIS IS A
FANTASTIC BILL -- IT BY -- THE
IF I COULD -- BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR -- I'D BE THANKFUL.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI.
WELL WE APPRECIATE IT NO NO
SHOWS OF SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
DURING THE HEARING THANK.
MS RICE JR [inaudible]
YES SO [inaudible]
I'M A YOU KNOW STRUGGLING A
LITTLE BIT WITH THIS BILL IN THE
SENSE THAT TIME I AM I HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF MEASURES ON
TRANSPARENCY.
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED HOW THAT
YOU RAN BEFORE -- DISCLOSE IN
THE TOP THREE DONORS WHEN IT
COMES.
TO YOU KNOW.
DELIBERATE POLITICAL ADS BY
PACKS AND AND OTHERS -- IN THIS
CASE YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE KIND
OF MORE FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE HAD
AREA OF THINGS.
AND SO.
AS I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THOSE ARE LIKE.
DIFFERENT GROUPS COULD BE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE COULD BE --
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
WHERE THEY HAVE ESSENTIALLY
COLLECTED MONEY FROM PEOPLE JUST
TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF VARIOUS
DIFFERENT ISSUES RIGHT -- AND SO
THEY MIGHT RUN AN AD ULTIMATELY.
GEARED AT ADVOCATING FOR THAT
FOR FOR A SPECIFIC ISSUE -- AND
YOU'RE SAYING ON THOSE ONES THEY
WOULD HAVE.
TO PUT THE TOP THREE DONORS
RIGHT BUT THE PERSON MIGHT A
DONATED RATE.
JUST TO SUPPORT.
THE GROUP ITSELF NOT NECESSARILY
TO SAY HEY I WANT TO SUPPORT.
PUTTING OUT THAT POLITICAL LAD
RIGHT SUCH RIGHT FEEL LIKE IT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FROM ONE
MORE LIKE DONATING.
TO POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEES.
FOR THE SPECIFIC PURPOSES OF
THAT ELECTION OF TRYING TO
ADVOCATE ON THAT SAY THAT
PROPOSITION OR FOR THAT
CANDIDATE -- AS OPPOSED TO WEAR
HEY WE'RE WE'RE KIND OF MORE
GENERALLY COLLECTING
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM PEOPLE TO
SUPPORT.
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW JUST THE
PROMOTION OF IDEAS IN GENERAL
RIGHT AND AND THOSE THOSE
COMMITTEES MIGHT ULTIMATELY.
DO OTHER THINGS OTHER THAN --
ISSUE ADVOCACY RIGHT.
SO I MEAN IS THERE A DIFFERENT
DISTINCTION THERE MAY BE KIND OF
CAN YOU [inaudible]
MAYBE JUST.
RESPOND TO THAT A LITTLE BIT I
JUST FEEL LIKE MAYBE THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT.
IT'S NOT THE SAME EXACT ANIMAL
OR TELL ME WHAT IT IS YEAH.
WHY APPRECIATE?
THE POINT ASSEMBLY MAN I WOULD
HAVE TO THINK THROUGH THAT ISSUE.
A LITTLE BIT I GUESS SOB.
IN ALLOWED TREND A BITE AT THAT
APPLE. TO ME.
NOT DIRECTLY ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION BUT IF YOU'LL ALLOW ME.
TO ME THIS IS A NATURAL
EXTENSION OF WHAT WE'VE DONE ON
THE DISCLOSURE FRAUD THAT.
YEAH WE HAVE FOCUSED ON THE
CAMPAIGN SIDE.
IN MY WAY OF THINKING.
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE GRAPPLE
WITH IN THIS BUILDING AND THE
LEGISLATIVE SIDE.
OF THIS EQUATION ARE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE CAMPAIGN SIDE
BECAUSE ACTUAL PUBLIC BUSINESSES
BEING DECIDED THIS BUILDING.
I THINK WE NEED TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT. FOR VIEWERS OF A
TELEVISION AD.
WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE?
AND WHAT THEIR PERSPECTIVE MIGHT
BE I THINK THERE'S SO MUCH
INFORMATION COMING OUT.
THE AVERAGE VOTER.
IF WE GET AT LEAST PROVIDE A
SENSE OF WHO THE MAJOR FUNDERS
ARE BEHIND THAT ORGANIZATION
THESE ARE THESE ARE MAJOR
FUNDERS BEHIND THAT GROUP.
AND THAT GROUP HAS CHOSEN TO TRY
TO INFLUENCE THIS BODIES PUBLIC
WORK.
IT JUST PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF CONTEXT FOR THE PUBLIC
AND BY EXTENSION THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IS SERVED.
YOUR POINT THOUGH ABOUT
SPECIFYING THAT THAT
CONTRIBUTION IS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO RUN AN ADVERTISEMENT.
I CAN LOOK AT THAT ISSUE AND SEE
IF THERE'S A WAY TO TIGHTEN THAT.
TO DRAW THAT NEXUS I DON'T KNOW
FROM A LEGAL OR EVEN A
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDPOINT IF
THAT GETS US INTO A DIFFICULT.
UP UP POSITION FROM MEN FROM IT
JUST THE AREA OF LAW BUT I WOULD
ALLOW TRENT.
WHO'S IMMERSED IN THESE KINDS OF
ISSUES TO COMMENT ON THAT IF YOU
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT FOR
MR GALLAGHER -- YEAH I I COULD
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT SOMETHING MEMBER SAID THAT
THE BILL DOES HAVE SOME
PROVISIONS IN IT RIGHT NOW IF TO
FOR INSTANCE -- ALLOW PEOPLE TO
EXCLUDE THE MONEY THAT THEY GIVE
UP FROM -- PURPOSES OF LOBBYING.
SO THAT IF YOU SAY I WANT TO
GIVE MONEY TO THE AND ARE A OR
C. D. A. OR SIERRA CLUB FOR TO
SUPPORT THEIR GENERAL STUFF BUT
I DON'T WANT MY MONEY TO BE USED
FOR LOBBYING.
THAN A YOU THOSE FUNDS WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE TO BE USED NOR SHOW
UP AS PART OF THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS SIMILARLY IF THEY'RE
USING ONLY SMALL DONORS -- FORT
TO FUND THESE ADS THEN IT WOULD
BE AGAIN THE ORGANIZATION THAT
WOULD SHOW UP IN ALL CASES
ORGANIZATION WHICH SHOW UP.
BUT NOT ANY SPECIFIC TOP THREE
FUNDERS SO THERE ARE SOME
PROTECTIONS IN THERE RIGHT NOW
WE BELIEVE BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
HAPPY. TO TO WORK TO TO TO MAKE
ANY ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION TO
MAKE THAT EXTRA CLEAR THAT
PEOPLE REALLY DON'T WANT THEIR
FUNDS TO BE USED FOR FOR
LOBBYING ISSUE ADS OR LOBBYING
THAN THAN THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
TO DISCLOSE THE TOP THREE FUNDER
[inaudible]
GOOD.
CAP.
I NEED THIS NOT QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NONE BRING BACK.
TO MISS MELINDA CLOSE.
WE JUST UP AGAIN THANK THE CHAIR
AND AND COMMITTEE -- FOR THEIR
GOOD WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND I
KNOW THERE IS -- LABOR
OPPOSITION ON THE MEASURE I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
FOLKS THAT -- ARE OPPOSED TO THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW MY INTEREST
IS NOT TO CREATE UNNECESSARY
BURDEN SOME.
REQUIREMENTS MY TEN IS A MORE
INFORMED PUBLIC SO THE PUBLIC
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND WHO IS
TRYING TO INFLUENCE THEM.
AND INFLUENCE THIS LEGISLATURE
AND I BELIEVE THE PUBLIC
INTEREST WILL BE SER BY A. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE OUT.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HOW MUCH IS THE
DISCLOSE ACT BROUGHT MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISEMENTS.
THIS BILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PRODUCING ISSUE ADS.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE WORKING
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE WITH ME IN MY COMMITTEE --
TO DATE -- AND WORKING WITH THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY SOME HAPPY TO
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING CALDERON HI
CALDERON I LOW.
WELL I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN AYE MULLIN AYE
WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL IS OUT ON A SIX
TO ZERO VOTE CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A LOT THE THAT QUITE SHOWS OF
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY EVERYONE WE
CAN GIVE FOLKS A MINUTE FOLKS
WANNA.
CLEAR THE ROOM.
OR NOT EITHER WAY [inaudible]
MR LOW.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT.
AB.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE MAYBE THIS IS
GIVE FOLKS A SECOND [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible] FOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WHICH IS A
VERY BASIC BILL TO ENSURE WHAT
YOU HEARD EARLIER WITH RESPECT
TO GETTING AT CORPORATE MONEY
OUT OF OUR ELECTIONS.
AT THIS FOR PREVENT A BUSINESS
ENTITY FROM DIRECTLY
CONTRIBUTING TO A CANDIDATE FOR
STATE OFFICE.
MAY FIRST OFF -- I THINK -- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING TO
TRY TO ADDRESS AND ACCOMMODATE A
SIMILAR THIS ISSUE.
AS FORMER CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL WE'VE ALWAYS
TRIED TO INCREASE THE TYPE OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WITHIN THE OUR ELECTORAL PROCESS --
THAT STILL CONTINUES TO THIS DAY
AND I KNOW THAT ARE FOR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CONTINUALLY
ADVOCATE FOR THE SAME TYPE OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE WISH TO SEE
IN OUR ELECTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE JUST THESE
NOTIONS OF A CITIZENS UNITED AND
THE NOTION THAT CORPORATIONS CAN
SPEAK AS PEOPLE OF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT FUND MAINLY.
I HAVE A DISAGREEMENT WITH AND
WHAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU IS A
BILL TO PREVENT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE DIRECTLY FROM
BUSINESS ENTITIES AS DEFINED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU MAY KNOW AND IS AS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS THERE ARE TWENTY
TWO STATES IN THE UNION THAT
HAVE SIMILAR.
TYPE OF PROPOSALS ON THE BOOKS
WITH RESPECT TO RESTRICTING
DIRECT CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
BUSINESS ENTITIES.
TO CANDIDATES FOR PUBLIC OFFICE.
A SIMILAR MUST ALSO ADMIT THAT
THIS IS.
OF SOMEONE AWKWARD A 2% AS SUCH
A A MEASURE BEING THAT SO WE ALL
KNOW AS A LIKE TO OFFICIALS FOR
PUBLIC OFFICE WE HAVE.
TO A CAMPAIGN AND MAKE THE
NECESSARY EFFORTS TO SUPPORT OUR
REELECTION EFFORTS -- BUT I DO
THINK THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO
PLAY BY THE RULES WE MUST
CONTINUALLY STRIVE. FOR THE TYPE
OF THINGS THAT WE WISH TO SEE AN
ENSURING THAT WE CAN GET
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS A TO
REFLECT THE TYPE OF VALUES THAT
WE HAVE AS PEOPLE AS THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN IN OUR DEMOCRACY SO.
AGAIN BEFORE YOU IT IS WILL
RECOGNIZE THAT -- ARGUABLY THIS
PROPOSALS ONE PROPOSAL TO GET.
THE INFLUENCE OF MONEY OUT OF
POLITICS BUT AS AS WELL
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THESE SAME TYPE OF RESOURCES
COULD THEN SIMPLY BE PUT INTO
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES AGAIN
THE WHOLE NOTION OF A CITIZENS
UNITED BUT AGAIN.
I CANNOT JUST SIT BY WITH THE
STATUS QUO AND CONSUMABLE
SUBMITS.
TO OUR BODY FOR ADDITIONAL
EFFORTS FOR CONSIDERATION WITH
RESPECT TO ENCOURAGING THAT TYPE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS SO AGAIN.
OF A FORCE IS THE PROPOSAL TO
PROHIBIT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM BUSINESS ENTITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
CANDIDATES FOR STATE OFFICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS HELLO.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK I SAID I
SAID IT CLEARLY AND AGAIN.
NO MATTER WHAT THE DECISION OF
THIS BODY IS I WANT TO AGAIN
COMMEND OUR COMMITTEE COMMITTEES.
STAFF AS WELL AS COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP FOR CONTINUALLY TO
FIND WAYS.
TO ACCOMMODATE THIS ISSUE IN
THIS NOTION OF MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS AN EQUAL VOICE AND
HAD WE GET OF THE NOTION OF THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN TO PARTICIPATE
IN OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
AND IF YOU SEEN BEFORE US HERE
TODAY ON A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
WE HAVE PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND WE PASSED EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PASS.
THIS IS JUST ADDITIONAL ARROW IN
THE QUIVER TO FOCUS ON THAT
NOTION OF ENSURING THAT TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND RESPECT IT
CAN ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LOW.
YOU YOU ARE OFTEN THAT -- MAN
AHEAD OF YOUR TIME -- AND IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT MIGHT BE THE
CASE WITH THIS ISSUE TODAY -- IT.
BUT I IN IN THE THE MOTION --
THE BILL CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE --
MOTION OR SECOND -- BUT I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE -- ON CAMPAIGN FINANCE
TRANSPARENCY ON IMPROVING ACCESS
TO THE BALLOT -- AND AND MANY
OTHER ISSUES IN THE ELECTION
SPACE -- AS WELL AS MANY OTHERS
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON ON THIS ISSUE -- IN THE
YEARS TO COME -- AS WELL AS MANY
OTHERS SO -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT LET'S OPEN UP
ITEMS FOR MEMBERS WHO WERE
ABSENT FROM -- FROM PREVIOUS
VOTES [inaudible]
THE JOB.
I'M MISTER GALLAGHER WHICH YOU --
AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER NOW.
THE BILL IS OUT ON A SIX TO ONE
VOTE.
YEAH.
MEETINGS ADJOURNED THANK YOU